ja und vor dem Gebäude auf der anderen
Straßenseite ist uns jetzt live
zugeschaltet Ralf Zimmermann von Siefert
er beobachtet die Ereignisse für uns vor
Ort Ralf bringen Sie uns doch bitte mal
auf den neuesten Stand ihrer
Erkenntnisse
die neuesten Stand in wird um 12 Uhr
heute in einer Pressekonferenz geben
insgesamt hat sich die Polizei relativ
zurückgehalten mit Informationen gestern
Abend heute Nacht sowieso aber auch
heute morgen noch ähm es ist gestern
gegen 21 Uhr dieser Einzeltäter davon
kann man wohl auch ausgehen in dieses
Gebäude hinter mir eingedrungen und hat
dort eben wild um sich geschossen in mit
mehreren
Salven aus einer aus einer Schusswaffe
auf eine
maschinenwaffe war oder einer
automatische Waffe war oder eine
einfache Schusswaffe ist noch nicht klar
und hat sechs Personen getötet und dann
wohl auch sich selbst jedenfalls als die
Polizei um 21 Uhr etwas hier ankam die
waren sehr schnell da die Polizei haben
Sie noch einen einzelnen Schuss in im
oberen Stockwerk wurde abgefeuert den
haben sie noch hören können und haben
dann festgestellt dass dort eine
einzelne Person gelegen hat das ist im
Grunde der Sachverhalt von von gestern
Abend mehrere Tote wie gesagt mehrere
Schwerverletzte ob noch Menschen in
Lebensgefahr schweben ist nicht klar
dazu auch heute Mittag wahrscheinlich
dann mehr von der Polizei ja wir werden
die Pressekonferenz um 12 Uhr auch hier
bei Phoenix natürlich live übertragen
sagen Sie uns nur eins Ralf die Polizei
war ja wohl sehr schnell vor Ort und hat
scheinbar sehr umsichtig gehandelt gibt
es dazu Erkenntnisse
ja das war eine das ist ein Hamburger
Konzept was hier gemacht worden ist dass
man sozusagen im Streifendienst auch
Polizisten hat die dann aber schnell zu
besonderen Lagen hinzugezogen werden
können und das war so eine Einheit die
gerade auf dem Weg nach Hause war
sozusagen es war ja schon relativ spät
am Abend und die konnten dann direkt
hierher gebracht werden dass deshalb war
die Polizei sehr schnell vor Ort und
deshalb hat vielleicht der Täter auch
dann seine schreckliche Taten beenden
müssen sozusagen und hat sich selbst
gerichtet das wird man alles
möglicherweise etwas näher erfahren
heute Mittag ähm wer der Täter ist weiß
man nicht die Polizei spricht ja von
einer Amok Tat und trotzdem ist sehr
wahrscheinlich und verdichten sich die
[Musik]
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass der Täter eine
Beziehung hatte zu dieser Gemeinde der
Zeugen Jehovas also das ist
möglicherweise ein Mitglied gewesen ist
ein ehemaliges Mitglied oder jemand
jedenfalls der mit Menschen aus dieser
Gemeinde aus dieser Gemeinschaft dieser
religiösen Gemeinschaft Beziehung gehabt
hat also das alles müssen wir etwas noch
abwarten und erfahren das heute Mittag
wahrscheinlich jedenfalls oder sehr viel
mehr als das was wir was wir bisher
wissen live war das aus Hamburg
zugeschaltet mein Kollege Ralf
Zimmermann von Siefert ganz herzlichen
Dank